community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
miracle flights is the cure for the
distance as they cover the flights for
children and their families when
treatment is far from them findlay
automotive group the sponsors of this
segment have been a proud supporter of
miracle flights and a friend of levi's
for many years here's the story
[Applause]
so today we're here with miracle flights
one of our favorite charities national
charity based here in las vegas and
we've got their mascot miles here with
us and we've also got my friend mark
brown who's the ceo of miracle flights
and mark tell us a little bit about what
miracle flights does so we're one of the
few charities in the country that fly
sick kids to distant medical care so if
a child has a
disease and only doctor is halfway
across the country we pay for those
airline flights and typically we do
about 600 flights a month wow that's
awesome so and you guys just had a
special kind of reached a special
milestone here lately right we just
celebrated our 150 000 flight we've been
in las vegas for 35 years so it took us
that long to get there but it was an
amazing event a young man that has club
foot he's three years old and he walked
down the escalator at mccarran airport
without cass and it was a really touchy
moment it was exciting wow that's
awesome so we have uh levi here with us
today and he's been someone that's flown
with you quite a few times right yeah
levi was actually the recipient of our
100 000 fight he's flown over 30 times
and he's a really special young man he's
one of the few in the country that has
this rare form of dwarfism but he
doesn't let it get him down he wakes up
every day and he's a fighter and he goes
for it so i live in mississippi and
we're flying to
chicago and
wilmington just about every eight weeks
when i when i was younger and
we were stressing out you know to
cleaning uh credit cards and all that uh
stuff and we finally found american flex
and it was like
thank you
we're here at philly chevrolet so you
know we know that you like cars right
do i like cars
that's pretty good couple years ago we
let you uh you went for a ride with a
lamborghini over at our lamborghini
store today
we're gonna maybe take a ride in the
corvette how about that sounds great
[Music]
we thought that maybe you'd like this
2022 corvette i thought we'd maybe
introduce you to kevin one of our
managers here and let him take you for a
ride what do you think i'm down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so levi how was your ride it was awesome
do you like that car yes you want to
step inside the paperwork come on of
course you're gonna ask me that
thanks for coming to visit it you know
we get so many calls from parents
needing our services we couldn't do this
without partners like findlay and of
course without the community so if
anybody is out there that's seeing us
and wants to help please go to our
website miraclefights.org
thank you again to findlay automotive
group for sponsoring this segment for
more information on this cause visit
miracleflights.org